hello and welcome to this video playing
Sakura Sakura hmm you never know so d 4
t's picking up his book and it says
don't I'd have sex yeah the road goes in
defense I don't have a good recipe
against this morning i recently saw this
line in a book i'm trying it but i don't
think it is particularly great to be
perfectly honest we'll see let's see
what happens at least I've got the two
bishops sorry for the moment at least oh
he doesn't believe in the power of
bishops he gives me to push ups against
two nights this is a nice of him
actually so what you do there till you
hear back
so G file is open the only thing is I
don't have my rooks are not connected
that's what I'm trying to say how to how
to do this I could ever get to tick on
age six to twenty won't even need I
wouldn't even need to have the rocks
connected but it's difficult to get this
going night h5 is a move that I don't
like to see as well maybe no in the
night eh 5s is particularly strong
efore would be cool but it doesn't work
him take stakes 94 we'd also love to
have my queen on f5 this would be really
brilliant maybe I can go for this
recruiting keeps my Ruca out of play but
okay you cannot have it all ok so here I
can actually grab one D 59 f 426 yeah
let's do it
so big pawn and queen to you for is good
if i can get it in budgeting made and
trading stuff Queenie form
Bishop takes I take the rook and I take
the night but this is still looking
better I think getting for this
fantastic pawn mass in the center
okay those pawns they should be pretty
strong I can also i mean this looks
terrible to take on h7 to be honest I'm
still doing it I want my rook into the
game a1 rook and the pawn should should
be a good enough to win on their own I
didn't see that move which is kind of
annoying
after chicks he wants to play g5 Wow I
know I know I know I've spotted this
idea took took too long I thought King
it to what he has g5 but okay I can go
kill you three anyway okay track down to
one minute
so time morning i will do a look f 3 f 7
have eight it's the winning idea and one
minute should be enough to do this check
check check black resigns okay so let's
have a an overview about this game this
is a let's head a real sideline I mean
this is definitely everything's
definitely okay four foot black but I'm
absolutely sure that you shouldn't take
on f3 and this is just a bad idea it is
not only giving wipe the total bishop
pad also gives white controller waiting
for which is something that is usually
one of flex potential trauma sale like
h6 let's say instead of this let's say
he goes here and i have to now decide if
i want to take or not because if I don't
he can do something like this and this
is as I said one of the positive sides
of blacks position that you can often
control you for and put a night down and
this is not possible anymore here so
here I think I should be in good shape
probably here you can improve especially
considering the regrouping then I went
for now yeah this doesn't work manage
five just blunders material he has to
keep defending with them with other
moves group too eh or something like
let's say I go here and yeah maybe this
one after which I have to decide if I
want to play something simpler or
something complicated yeah this is just
material this is forcing the the Queen
trade Bishop takes is also not bad but
this is stronger just a huge pond roller
in the center yeah the captures is
probably not the best move to be honest
I mean maybe you but you have to hear I
did not see that counter play yeah I
probably should play rook t1 here he had
g5 this would have been a very cool
shower unbelievable this isn't that
brilliant yeah that was a big mistake
that I allowed that no everything is
spec dragon order Jan and white white
wins with the with the passes mmhmm yeah
I did I shouldn't have allowed five that
was a pretty pretty awful thing to do ok
I hope you enjoyed the video thanks for
watching